PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Wait for it.
[DEEP SOUND]
Well, I knew that
was going to happen.
But in real life, we
rarely get advance notice
for a disruptive event.
Stay tuned as we discuss how
to build a solid business
continuity plan.
I'm Priyanka, and
welcome to Anthos 101.
Many of you might have
backup and disaster recovery
plans in place.
But we rarely get notified
that a disruptive event
might happen.
Even with some lead time, things
can still go wrong and impact
business continuity.
Let's answer seven
key questions that
can help you go beyond
traditional backup and DR.
Question number 1.
Are your applications
architected
for high availability
and data redundancy?
Anthos GKE helps you architect
for high availability and data
redundancy by offering
two types of clusters,
zonal and regional.
In a zonal cluster topology,
a cluster's control
plane and nodes all run
in a single compute zone
that you specify when
you create the cluster.
In a regional cluster,
masters and nodes
are replicated across multiple
zones within a single region.
Regional clusters consist
of three masters, quorum,
offering higher availability
than a zonal cluster.
You can minimize the risk of
disruption to your services,
as well as expedite
the upgrade process
through unique features like
surge upgrades and release
channels.
Anthos also enables
data protection
through disk snapshots stored in
any regional or multi regional
locations across Google Cloud.
And disks can be attached to
regional clusters and fail-over
if a zone fails.
You can combine these with
Anthos-enabled software
from the Google
Cloud Marketplace
to enable high
availability applications
such as [INAUDIBLE],, Word
Works Enterprise, Robbins
Storage, [INAUDIBLE] APS.
Question number 2, can
your apps scale up and down
without code changes?
When you work with
Anthos, you are
adopting modern Cloud native
technologies like containers,
serverless, and
service mesh that
enables micro services
based applications.
These are modular
architectures that
make it easier to
upgrade and scale
up and down than a tightly
coupled monolithic application.
Question number 3, do you
have consistent management
across on-prem and
multi-cloud environments?
We started the series by
answering the question, what
is Anthos, where we
covered how and those
can help you consistently secure
and operate existing apps,
develop and deploy new apps
across disparate locations,
while offering
centralized visibility
and management of resources.
Question number 4, are
you finding and fixing
bugs before moving
to production?
Well, the only way
to ship bug free code
is by catching bugs and
fixing them before deployment.
With increasing adoption
of hybrid and multi cloud,
you need a modern CICD pipeline
to automatically build, test,
and reliably deploy to
different environments.
To learn more about how to
build a modern CICD pipeline
with Anthos, check out
a previous episode.
Question number 5, have
you defined and implemented
measurable Service
Level Objectives
or SLOs for your apps?
It's crucial to define RTO and
RPO for business continuity.
RTO, or Recovery Time
Objective, is the amount of time
an application can be
unavailable without causing
significant damage
to your business.
RPO, or Recovery
Point Objective,
is the tolerance
of how much data
can be lost before critically
impacting your business.
It helps to consider modernizing
your existing applications
to cloud native architecture.
This will help you deliver
uninterrupted services
at an optimal cost.
With Anthos, you can easily
set SLOs for your services
and monitor them.
That brings me to
question number 6,
can you proactively mitigate
failures in your applications?
Anthos dashboards
provides built in SLOs
so you can improve
the observability
and proactively
mitigate failures,
just like Google SREs.
For more details, check out
how to improve observability
using golden signals episode
in the Anthos 101 series.
Question number 7, do you have
access to skills to develop
and maintain your apps?
Now, this might sound
like a learning problem,
but having a standardized
technology platform, which
makes it easy for you to
manage existing applications
and build new ones helps.
With Anthos, your teams
have access to skills
to develop and maintain apps,
not just in one environment,
but across multiple
environments.
To summarize, here's
a checklist of how
to go beyond business
continuity with Anthos.
Develop high availability
apps with data redundancy.
Scale flexibly
without code changes.
Find and fix bugs before
moving into production.
Manage consistently across
on-prem and multi-cloud.
Implement measurable SLOs,
including RTO and RPO values.
Mitigate app
failures proactively.
Gain sufficient
access to skills.
Today we learned that Anthos
can help you build a next gen
business continuity plan beyond
traditional backup and disaster
recovery.
Read beyond business
continuity white paper
linked below to learn more.
And for more Anthos
content, don't
forget to subscribe and check
out the entire Anthos 101
playlist.